so when did you decide to give up
teaching though and just do comedy did
you without obviously it was always your
dream
it was always my dream it was what i was
working hard at and yeah i was already a
young father
and i had my daughter was already six
months old and
and you know i lived an hour outside of
manhattan is jenny right there
and i was living an hour outside of
manhattan
in my hometown of long beach new york
and it was a real struggle to be able to
get to the clubs and then come back and
so on and then my wife janice will be
married 51 years
in june wow um said i'm going to go back
to work
i'm going to go back to work she had a
really good job at a assistant to the
dean of theater at a
at a junior college on the island and we
had health benefits and she said you
know what
you take care of jenny all day i'll come
home from
the school around five hand her off do
whatever you have to do
and go into the city and become the
comedian i know that you can be
and it was the greatest greatest gift
of her selflessness as a young mother
with a six month old
to trust me and i was mr mom way before
it was popular you know i was so this
was 1973 in a little bit and
it's really i look at it as a real
turning point in my life
not only as a father but as a human
being yeah because it gave me
perspective
on on what we're here for and what
you're responsible for
and to to love someone so selflessly and
take care of her and make sure that
she's healthy and happy and educated and
even in those early days and it forever
bonded us i mean it was a
really great important time in my life
wow and what an amazing i mean now
i get congratulations by the way 51
years that's
insane in any in any environment but
especially in the entertainment industry
that's that's kind of unheard of
so that's that's amazing but i love i
guess the lesson there too is just the
support was you know always there and
the partnership was always there do you
think that that's basically
how that it's lasted so long what's your
advice for staying married 51 years
um have a girlfriend oh you know what
we still learn from each other we still
love being together this you know this
year was such a test of that
i mean i've been in this chair since
last march 12th
basically um and and just we just have
so much fun and keep discovering new
things about each other
and i think that's the most important
thing is to still
always be curious and and find out more
about each other
yeah oh well you are lucky that's a
beautiful relationship that you've had
yep i'm still here just waiting for you
to subscribe
if you don't i'll be trapped in this box
forever